texas republic republicans declare biden
illegitimately elected reject 2020
election certification they say a
component of the 2022 platform adopted
by texas republicans on june 18th
rejects the outcome of the 2020 u.s
presidential election calling it a
constitutional violation we all know how
much youtube loves this story quote
the texas gop said we believe the 2020
election violated article 1 and 2 of the
us constitution that various secretaries
of state illegally circumvented their
state legislatures in conducting their
elections in multiple ways including by
allowing ballots to be received after
november 3rd 2020 the resolution reads
they go on to say they believe that
substantial election fraud in key
metropolitan areas significantly
affected results in five key states in
favor of joseph robinette biden jr now i
don't care for that last statement to be
completely honest i uh i i just i don't
care for it i think that a lot of really
angry people voted against trump and i
think it's kind of a cop-out now i know
a lot of people really you know believe
in the fraud narrative i think the
bigger issue is we know for a fact that
in several states they did change the
rules there were legal challenges they
were never ruled on the merits many of
them
pennsylvania is the perfect example and
this is what i want to highlight in this
story right away texas v pennsylvania
was 2020 texas said exactly what they're
saying now that various states violated
the constitution and the way they
handled the voting the supreme court
said we won't hear it okay if someone
comes to you and says i believe this
thing happened and you go don't care i'm
not listening they're gonna say okay
well it's not like my mind was changed
if the if the supreme court took the
case heard the arguments maybe now we
would have some resolution so if you've
got a bone to pick take it up with
roberts and the rest of the supreme
court alito and thomas are the only ones
willing to hear it the reason why i
don't care for the fraud narrative for
one i'm not completely convinced i'm
sorry i just i'm just not i think a lot
of people were very much excited to vote
against donald trump and more
importantly
it's it's it's demoralizing and it is um
it's it's voter suppression in a sense
you're basically telling people to give
up but i'll tell you this
if there is a question about the
constitutionality or the rules in an
election that's something that should be
investigated it should be litigated so
that that way there is confidence in the
election
my i think what's most important here is
not necessarily the argument about 2020
because we're going on two years later
you know for the most part i think the
issue is
they never resolved the issue yeah that
republicans have and because of that
we're now moving into a midterm where
already we had one county otero county
refusing to certify the results and now
we're moving into 2024 it's going to be
even crazier you think texas is going to
is going to be willing to play with
these other states when they were like
you wouldn't even listen to our
arguments in the first place our mind
has not been changed and now they're
building a platform based on that that
uh that belief
so how do you think conservatives are
going to be viewing the supreme court
going forward because historically
people have been really excited about
the supreme court we treat them we treat
those justices like their gods like
they're like they're more human they're
better than us human beings they're
infallible they can't do anything wrong
do you think that's going to change as a
result of this the supreme court is
viewed that way yeah i think a lot of
people view the supreme court as though
they're they're otherworldly beings and
they're infallible
what's the what's the salary of a
supreme court justice isn't it like 180
it's not that much it's not very high
yeah right
so you know i bring that up because yeah
a lot of people view the supreme court
as just like this you know all
powerful entity and i'm like some dude
just tried to kill kavanaugh and there's
like nothing he can do about it they're
protesting in front of his house and
there's nothing he can do about it and
he only makes 180k per year that is not
a lot of money to be dealing with this
level of threat through these threats
and violence yeah and they have no
enforcement authority
the the supreme court can come out and
be like we want this and everyone go no
and they go but you have to
looks like they make two hundred and
eighty thousand i'm sorry two eighty
chief justices not 180.
still yeah
every year they get a raise it looks
like 280's a lot of money
but like to be one of the most famous
and hated people that's the problem fame
and money they don't always scale
together and if you're super famous and
dirt poor you can't hire security you
can't afford it well that's a big
problem there's also apparently bad fame
when people want to murder you that's
not a good thing that's pretty horrible
political fame is not necessarily
positive
yeah no that's why you you'd be better
off hosting like you know look at us in
this political political show we'd be
better off we were just talking about
like johnny depp and amber heard and
doing pop culture stuff i think that
you're jealous
all right a little bit to be honest
i think the supreme court's got way too
much power man i think that there should
not be seven eight nine ten people
deciding the fates of the entire nation
it's insane yeah that's completely
insane to me how about supreme court
precedent
like
meaning what exactly i mean what do you
think about the fact that they can
decide something and then that's just
the law i think it's absolutely
ridiculous that you would give eight
people that power 12 people it's like it
is legislation it's not finally it's not
viewed as legislation but we treat it as
legislation well
i mean i i think there are issues
the conversations to be had about you
know the supreme court for sure and
authority but it is the interpretation
of the law as the legislation has passed
it right so
i think the founding fathers did a
really really great job trying to craft
you know government i think it's the
best we've seen so far certainly i think
we could probably do better you know the
idea that this is the end all be all of
good government it's not the case but
more importantly i think you know
probably early on it was way better than
it is now yeah absolutely i think it's
probably corrupted over a long period of
time well it's scaled up dramatically
social media has changed a lot of the
way people interact with just political
leaders in general like that they can
get a tweet they can get a hundred
thousand tweets messages a day like back
in the day a hundred years ago they were
live on their farm and that's where they
were and no one really knew where they
lived or well so i
i was reading about the john brown raids
and bleeding kansas and it's like 10
years or it's like six years before the
civil war
and i was uh i was reading about the
raid on harper's ferry yeah dude walked
into harper's ferry and took over like
that there was no communication so when
they walk in with a bunch of dudes with
guns they're like okay you're in charge
now the only reason they ended up
getting caught was because there was a
train they had stopped and then john
brown let the train leave they made it
to i think baltimore and then
immediately got in the telegraph and was
like yo a bunch of abolitionists took
over the city and they're doing like a
slave revolt killed a lot of people
yeah i think it was five people
five people died i could be wrong john
brown's hardcore but bleeding kansas was
nuts that was that so that was like
warfare that was just outright war it
was civil it was a state civil war
so uh but anyway i was reading about
this and i'm thinking like if anything
like that happened today the moment
someone banged on the door the tax the
tweet would be out and everyone in the
world would know what was happening the
air force would be scrambled the air
force is already up there waiting they'd
just be like two hours out or less oh
they know before you're they're watching
on your phone and your gps as you're go
going to harpers ferry so like if if
john brown existed today they'd be like
hey we noticed those five guys we've
been spying on are all in the same place
and they're heading towards this armory
send in the troops watch list yep boom
done done
so anyway
i bring that up because i'm thinking
about today and i'm thinking about how
social media has changed everything
that the the amount of time it took for
the civil war to happen it wouldn't be
the same today today it would be like
it's at the moment it kicks off everyone
knows it kicked off mm-hmm a bunch of
triggers
would happen like their power would get
shut down here then the power will get
shut down here then you see an explosion
while three
stall so are people really
people are talking about secession or
balkanization which is the nicer way to
put it
how many people do you think are
seriously talking about open civil war
not many no i i think i
bro i it was trending today on twitter
102 000 tweets on twitter but on the
morning i don't think they're actually
talking about real civil war they don't
know what that means that doesn't mean
that the reality doesn't matter hide in
a hole and hope that you don't get a
bomb dropped on you every day you're
right but that doesn't matter like
they're using the people people think
suppressors go pew pew pew because they
watched a movie yeah they they read a
book about civil war and i think they
know what it is they the these antifa
people i mean look at what happened with
uh aaron danielson in seattle took two
to the chest some grand just
people understand civil war is going to
be you're going to get groceries and
then all of a sudden an ied blows up
next to you and you're just a random
person has nothing to do with this
that's the kind of reality of these
conflict that's the reality of this
conflict you had those antifa people in
portland walking around with rifles and
they pointed the gun at the guy in the
truck and said you know stop and the guy
gets out with his gun
you're going to be living in your house
and some and and all of a sudden one day
people are going to walk up and be
shooting at each other and balls are
going to fly it would be like they're
blowing up the freeways all the freeways
would be dis dissolved they would be
gone in a civil war and then the chinese
would invade the ccp would invade okay
well at some point the national guard or
the american military is going to come
into that equation so i guess it's just
we wonder when because we saw in
portland
well in portland it certainly wasn't
civil war but
didn't it look like it just on a small
scale
yeah civil strife i i suppose so it and
i anticipate that if anything like that
happens it's going to start off with
civil strife it's not going to pop off
with someone in a militia declaring
civil war
so i'll
i think when you bring up the national
guard there's like a like i suppose a
more worrying reality of
whichever faction is in control yeah is
holding the conch shell essentially is
wielding the power of of law enforcement
and military
so
donald trump was unwilling to say that
tom cotton said sending the truce trump
was unwilling to do it and he's the
conservative one and right now you can
see the fed's going to a garage to
investigate a pull rope you can see the
feds
ag unwilling to to go after the
protesters illegally protesting in front
of the homes of supreme court justices
so it very much looks like uh the
reality is
the democrats are willing to use the
power the conservative the republicans
are not and that means if there ever
wasn't an act of conflict then those who
are in law enforcement who are just
going to follow orders are going to be
following wars of democrats so
that's because they'll be they'll be
involved thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there